Завершується ціла епоха.
Після 16 років при владі Анґела Меркель більше не буде канцлеркою.
Хто ж наступний?
Щоб це визначити, у Німеччині проводять федеральні вибори.
І це складний процес. Але цьому є поважні причини.
Перше, що вам потрібно знати:
Німці не голосують безпосередньо за свого канцлера.
Вони голосують, щоб обрати депутатів парламенту - Бундестагу.
Вони роблять це кожні 4 роки.
На відміну від багатьох інших країн, таких як США, усі громадяни Німеччини
автоматично реєструються для голосування, коли їм виповнюється 18 років.
Незалежно від статі, релігії чи політичних переконань.
На виборах 2021 року голосуватимуть понад 60 мільйонів осіб.
Кожен голос рахується однаково.
Німці можуть віддати свій голос поштою або особисто в день виборів.
Виборчі дільниці є у школах, музеях, де завгодно.
Про точність і оперативність процесу дбають працівники виборчих дільниць.
Ми старанно виконуємо свої обов'язки.
Саме він відповідає за те, щоб у день виборів все пройшло гладко.
Ми надзвичайно прискіпливі щодо виборів. І ретельно перевіряємо список виборців,
щоб пересвідчитися, що та чи інша особа має право голосу.
Після того, як це перевірено, виборець може починати.
Але є правила:
Голосування відбувається наодинці.
Ніхто інший не бачить, що всередині кабіни для голосування - або де поставили галочку в бюлетені.
І нікому не дозволяється впливати на вибір виборців.
Штори закриті, селфі не дозволяються.
У бюлетені для голосування є не одна шпальта, а дві.
У першій німці голосують за кандидата від свого округу.
Той, хто набере більшість голосів, автоматично потрапляє до парламенту.
А в другій шпальті виборці обирають політичну партію.
Це друге голосування визначає загальний відсоток, який кожна політична партія отримує у Бундестазі.
А для того, щоб партія потрапила до Бундестагу, вона має набрати бодай 5 відсотків голосів -
щоб запобігти партійній роздробленості й не затримувати законодавчий процес.
Є ще кілька нюансів. Наприклад, додаткові мандати.
Іноді партія отримує більше прямих депутатських мандатів під час першого голосування, ніж від голосування за партію.
Оскільки кожному кандидату, який виграє виборчий округ, гарантується місце у Бундестазі, партія може зберегти ці додаткові місця.
Внаслідок цього парламент стає більшим, ніж його базове число - 598 місць.
Але це дійсно складно - тому ми пояснимо це іншим разом.
Говорячи про складне: жодні вибори у Німеччині не проходять без паперового сліду!
З міркувань безпеки мало що оцифровано.
У нас, у Німеччині, "олдскульний" процес. Ми все ще рахуємо за допомогою паперових бюлетенів, а не у цифровому вигляді.
Це дуже прозоро для громадян. І в цьому плані я думаю, що ми маємо дуже гарний досвід за 70 років.
Але - сюрприз - таки відбувається деяка диджиталізація.
Остаточно звітувати про голосування працівники дільниць можуть з допомогою, наприклад, електронної пошти.
Або старого доброго телефону.
О 18:00 у день виборів оголошуються перші екзитполи.
Після підрахунку остаточних результатів ми переходимо до наступного кроку.
Пам'ятайте: результати виборів визначають відносну силу партій у Бундестазі.
Після свого обрання депутати об'єднуються у коаліцію, створюючи більшість.
Потім обирають канцлера.
Кожен крок цього процесу необхідний для забезпечення прозорої і точної системи голосування.